one of the great moments of LeWeb that
had stopped for a year because Gary
could not make it is Gary Vaynerchuk
that doesn't need much introduction and
doesn't need any preparation from me
because he's going to drive everything
I'm just going to take questions from
the room and have fun with him so Gary
are you here
welcome Gary thank you it's been uh what
your you missed one year only right
maybe two - we missed you Oh Paris good
to see you
great job by the way so you have not
slept for two days yes sorry because
that there's a deeper answer to that yes
I did not sleep for two days
we'll get we have mics ready so whatever
you want to switch to an interaction
with a room we can do that okay you want
to talk about your latest news you have
a book I do I released a book two weeks
ago called Jab Jab Jab right hook it's
my take on what's going on in the world
of storytelling specifically the
platforms where more and more spending
our times which is social networks on
mobile devices so what I tried to write
is a how-to book as a follow-up to my
why books crush'
and Thank You economy and so I wrote a
book that has 80 case studies where I
break down brands entrepreneurs apps
that do a good job on Facebook Twitter
Tumblr Pinterest Instagram snapchat vine
and ones that don't do as good of a job
because they think I think that map
check you know snapshots on snapchat oh
absolutely I think right now snapchat is
one of the most successful marketing
tools for me personally with my brand
because I think the biggest thing that
people want misunderstanding about
snapchat
no thank you Loic the thing that
everybody's misunderstanding with
snapchat in this room in in our space
right now is that everybody worries
about with right like everybody cares
about top-line numbers impressions
followers people care about dumb [ __ ]
data right they care they care about the
wrong thing they're carrying about
especially when they're fake especially
making like fake it how many medians so
far is do you have better BOTS or things
of that nature or don't get it doesn't
matter how
you have it matters how many care right
I mean I went through this in the
mid-90s right this is this is history
repeating itself I remember you telling
me about how important it was to build
your following of course completely
realized I'm full of [ __ ] you were at
the time no no I met you deep in the
2000s so let's not [ __ ] what what
what I talked about was building a fan
base that actually cared right so I went
through this in the mid-90s when I in 98
this was exactly said because not
because I'm so smart but because this is
my second rodeo right in 1996 when I was
building winelibrary.com I was trying to
build as many emails subscribers as
possible I started buying ads on email
lists luxury Doc if the founders of
luxury dot-com are watching right now
[ __ ] you let me explain in 1996 here in
1996 I bought luxury comm an ad on their
email list because they had two million
emails I thought it was gonna be
incredible I mean I didn't sleep the
night before I had Wine Library ready I
was gonna pack every order this was
gonna change my business
two million emails this is crazy when
they send that email at noon I'm gonna
be ready here comes all these wine
orders luxury calm it's gonna be the
best kind of customers and then it's you
know 30 minutes after the email goes out
and I'm like one order and I'm like I
probably didn't go out and I emailed
them and they're like we sent it and I
was like [ __ ] and literally at that
point I understood that it wasn't with
it was depth right and so by 1998 I
cared about open rates and click through
ratio and things that actually mattered
and so as Twitter came along and as
people in this space started I started
getting out there I wasn't worried about
building my Twitter following top line I
was worried about people actually caring
vayniacs
people that watched because at the end
of the day that's what matters
what snapchat is doing everybody is very
simple it's not about how many
impressions you get it's how much
attention you get the one thing
everybody in this room is tied by no
matter what you do
this room if you're a journalist b2b
conferences sell wine b2c startup app
developer I don't care what anybody in
this room does or watching at home on
livestream the number one thing we all
have to do is tell our story to somebody
along the path of them making a decision
before you tell your story you have to
have somebody's attention and what
snapchat does is it gives you the
attention I've not been able to make
something trend on Twitter for four
years once famous people actually
started coming on my days were over
right
trending right now the web is number one
Twitter trend no I'm joking me I don't
give a [ __ ] about you me I was unable to
make anything Trent you know back in
eight oh seven nine I can make things
trend with a tweet blah blah the first
time I've been able to make something
trend in the last three years was this
August when I sent a snapchat to 4,000
people how can you send us an episode to
4,000 people hustle it took me 49
minutes to select every person by hand
not this [ __ ] update product they
have that's called stories that suck
[ __ ] like people to use that the single
reason I thought snapchat should at
least consider to sell their company for
three billion dollars was cuz how shitty
their update was the last time around
makes me question if there's any real
product people there I mean I love the
company I fully believe that they
figured something out
I believe the attention matters I love
it but that last update was [ __ ] so they
lost a billion valuation well no I mean
it just scared me right I've been so
bullish on it I've been putting my ass
on the line about this is a very
important platform and they've let me
down a little bit but I hope evident
very soul oh yeah most most people here
in the room who has used snapchat in the
room yeah you got caught you got caught
admit right now that you got caught you
didn't expect that many don'ts to go up
in minute look in the camera and say you
were wrong where is it I was wrong that
was
let's clap that up keep that you've
never seen before first time let's see
that crater many times in these days
let's talk about second it's about
attention and so I took a picture of
myself holding up a bottle of wine with
a hashtag and I have to lose 5,000
people in two seconds a ton of them
posted that picture on Twitter with that
hashtag and I was able to make friend
and what it taught me was the lesson I
learned at 96 about open rates and
conversion which is it doesn't matter
how many with my million followers a
year or my two million on Google+ or
this time the other thing the 5,000 on
snapchat are real and more importantly
are paying attention are really focused
on it and and I think in general
everybody in this space when I mean the
space I mean this whole tech thing that
we're all a part of if you're smart
enough to be in this room or watching
right now we need to start caring a lot
more about the depth of our
relationships our customers our
opportunities and not the width because
it the same looks like you have a few
fines over there yeah I like this like
some it's most brands just care about
the audience right they buy they steal
by how many visitors
well brands have listened and so let me
most of you don't know who I am I run a
social media creative and strategy shop
now called vaynermedia that's right
what's that that's the plug
I'm sure asking me about the plug that
we should put some there oh no no I know
I mean this is wrong I'm just you know
vaynermedia is tell me about your
business my business right now so I have
the wine business that some of you know
winelibrary.com that runs itself and
then I spend all my time now on
vaynermedia which is a social media
strategy and creative shop so we produce
content so you monetize your knowledge
basically yeah it started with me we're
now 300 people we've gone to 300 people
we've gone from 20 to 300 the last 24
months so I've been operating right I've
been head down building another business
and now it's much more analytical and
there's other people with brains and we
have a real organization and so you
consult for brands is that your model no
what sounds like an agency no we are an
agency we're sorry we're very
unattractive no VC thinks I'm cool it's
very unattractive there's no big
multiple on the eBay da but we make a
fuckload of money it's weird
you're mean profit yes all right with no
funding it's a strange new concept it's
called profit Gary that will not take
you to four billion dollars in
valuations right listen I'm not gonna
suffer forty billion but more
importantly am grooming talent I'm
building an actual business my brother
AJ is my partner he got out of college
it was very important to me that he
learned how to run a P&L and not raise
money so we build a practical business
what thank you you know what I [ __ ]
love Paris you guys are clapping at the
right [ __ ] so we built this company we
do strategy and creative what I mean by
that is when we land the new client like
we just did with Mountain Dew or or
doves Dove soap or you know these big
brands I work with GE we walk in and we
actually ask them what do you want to
accomplish like what is your business
objective and what we then do is decide
which platforms that we think are the
most lucrative to convert that but let's
face it the most brands are totally
boring online right absolutely boring no
no no most people and brands and come
like everybody sucks
right like 99% of the [ __ ] that's in
screen now is garbage because because he
sucks and all they want is to provide
their crap absolutely and and but not
only marketing people like you know most
people suck because they just want to
promote their stuff and and that's how
do we fix that you have if I'm a sucky
Brown I am a but I don't want to piss
off anyone here you better be careful
cuz everybody is a sponsor of this
[ __ ] conference
what brand can I quote with a you know
upsetting anyone a toothbrush I mean run
so let's separate let's say I'm a
toothbrush no that's a good example
because no one cares about a toothbrush
right nobody cares about a smoke
detector but the last [ __ ] guy
figured it out right so I think I think
I think what it comes down to is this we
should the connected toothbrushes ok
like listen my toothbrush my toothbrush
would be texting me right now like get
to the dentist [ __ ] you know I mean
it's gonna happen the reason I came up
with the title of my last book Jab Jab
Jab right hook is to fix this problem I
want to start this dialogue which is
give give give and then ask the reason
I've been able to build businesses is I
don't think I'm entitled to anything I
actually think that's the biggest
problem we have right now this level of
entitlement just cuz you launch an app
doesn't mean you're gonna get users or
you're entitled to it so my big belief
is that you have to give you have to
give you have to give and then you have
the permission to conceivably ask for
the conversion the right hook and you
were in the plane but Evernote
Philippine was there was explaining
society says I've been giving for four
years ever not has been free even we did
premium like 5 bucks a month that's
right and now he sells products he sells
scanners and stuff guys in life a funny
you know the best way to get something
is to give something first
it you have the leverage I don't
understand how people don't understand
this now I understand why it happens
because a funny thing happens in the
game that we all play in in the world
where you raise money you're against the
clock you're burning and you're in bad
habits when you raise money you spend it
on dumb [ __ ] right because you've got a
lot of it and then it starts burning
quicker and what happens is you start
making bad decisions because you're
making decisions based on time not the
marathon for me because I've always been
self-funded and are self-sufficient I've
had the luxury of running the marathon
instead of the sprint when you're
running the sprint you're making very
quick decisions and you don't have the
patience required to give give give and
then ask and so what I hi
recommend everybody in this room give
thought to and who's watching is how do
you position yourself to actually create
patience so that you're able to execute
the right things that ultimately allow
you to have the leverage to go in and
ask for the sale because we're we have a
supply and demand issue we have a major
supply and demand issue we live in a
world now I don't know if you heard
about it but there's this new thing it's
called the Internet
right and what it's done is its created
a situation where the cost of entry into
the marketplace of almost anything you
do has collapsed and cost and speed of
getting to market so what happens is we
have dramatically more supply of
everything of information of apps of
products of services and so the consumer
has far more choice so we have to
provide more value than the fact that
we're in [ __ ] existence and so that
requires giving upfront and that's
something that I think most people are
uncomfortable doing and or the fact that
matters most people are wired and have
the DNA of worrying about what's in it
for them and not what's in it for their
consumers or partners how do you build a
following on snapchat i leveraged my
other platform is one by one well I
merged my other platforms because I
followers everywhere else I mean you
know I don't know if the slides up it's
not but lady was gonna go I mean was you
know forever I always put my Twitter and
Facebook handle I think it's kind of
interesting that I put my snapchat
handle it was I I didn't think that we
were gonna I didn't know what we're
gonna talk about but I asked back room
to put it up there because I want to
build it up I'm tweeting it out I'm
facebooking it out I've emailed it out I
want to build it up because that's where
my depth is coming right now but what's
the value of doing a snapchat for you
because it's emperor you know you have
the attention does it tell you amazing
thing Louis nothing is more important
than the attention of the end user
nothing the attention of the end user is
the cost of entrance to accomplish
anything
and so the attention snapchat is coming
that if you don't watch it now it's
gonna be gone forever that's right you
figure that's the interesting mode like
like Guy Kawasaki you might get a little
old I think
sometimes I don't know I just kidding
but he was saying I'm passing four times
on Twitter now he was repeating the
messages you know what he does right I
think that's an interesting strategy I
in 2003 opposite in 2013 I've posted the
same message on Twitter more than once
for the first time in seven years
because I agree with guy the stream is
so busy that if you have something you
want to say you have to be strategic and
I think and listen you give up doing
that no I didn't do it from o-62 mm now
I do it now I do you spam of a stream as
well I I don't think it's spam I think
that's your funny way to make a joke I
think what I'm doing is when it's when
it's when it's nine o'clock in the
morning Eastern Time and I want to say
something that's important that day I'm
smart enough to realize that six o'clock
in the morning in San Francisco and I
have a fan base Erin I need to wait if I
am a loyal follower of yours and I read
the tweets from Gary I see four times
the same crap you yes horrible I
understand on the flip side the reality
is the stream has become so busy that
I've looked at my data and my feedback
that people are missing it enough and
not to mention it's so fast everything
is microseconds that you're not so
[ __ ] devastated that you're seeing
something a second time it's not the end
of the world that I saw [ __ ] tweet a
second time not to mention given the
fact that I try very hard to provide
value and respond to everybody at scale
and put out good content I'm putting out
value it's not about how many times you
say listen somebody might be following
EULA week and you don't put out any good
[ __ ] content so it's a complete waste
of time
it could be could be
right I mean it so offensive a room
where we're having a little bit of fun
but the truth is the truth right the
fact that matter is if you're putting
out quality content you're probably less
upset that you saw the same quality
content twice versus ten pieces of
content over a month from somebody who's
bringing you no value at the end of the
day this is all about value it's about
value right it's you're either
entertaining people right
you're either creating a utility I mean
why didn't Instagram really work wasn't
a social network it made us better at
taking photos which we care about and
that utility made it extremely popular
and then all the other layers came in so
you can either be a utility you could be
escapism because all of our lives are
busy and intense and we need a little
bit of escapism or you could be
entertainment and if you don't
understand that just look at the front
of your phone I promise you the things
that are on the front of your phone sit
in one of those three categories and the
front of your phone what is on your home
screen on your phone is the single
clearest gateway into the psychology of
what human beings care about in today's
society Wow oh yeah I could be smart too
I don't I I can be entertaining anchors
but I've got some thoughts would you
like to keep talking alone or should we
enjoy our conversation so much whoo I am
actually trying to piss you off and I
fell so far you're like so mellow and
nice and I'm a new Gary Vee Louis yeah
you're like I mean you would have said
that well you yeah buddy
but when you have such a beautiful face
you can get away with anything
thank you Gary that's my eyes we're just
[ __ ] eyes Louis you're Gary so we'd
like to take some questions okay all
right where's the question here does
that that's what that's why they came
for like not for me as well let me
excuse me one second my friend that's a
whole other conversation one of the if I
thought that I could come to conferences
and just do QA I would if I was known
enough or if I didn't think people
thought it was lazy because I actually
think
back to what I just said earlier which
is value is what matters I think at a
conference the content you can go home
and watch anytime you want your
underpants right you don't think that is
amazing what you just said because we
put everything on YouTube live and we
post it all on YouTube everything for
free the content is there right and
unfortunately 90% of the people that
speak given the same [ __ ]
presentation for three years right so
you don't need to see it more than once
what I think is really interesting in
conferences is the engagement which is
why so many people are out in the hall
right now engaging with each other food
with Twitter or wall up so just see that
they hate this weekend no I see it and
number two I think I think the biggest
thing that we're gonna see after this
content play play itself out a little
bit I think the next thing and the one
thing that a lot of people should be
thinking about is access
I think access is an incredibly high
value proposition and that's why I want
to do Q&A right now we actually get to
engage during this limited time it's the
access yet you don't take the questions
yeah that's a very bad point it's good
yeah yeah I don't think we need a
connector toothbrush you're eating too
much chocolate like yeah we saw that
I know anyway why good why then deep you
said so I was thinking forget we chat
line Kakao Talk which by accident nobody
really GU mention in these two days
which I'm amazed it's absurd it's it's
American Pie yeah could be deeper than
what's up can you mean I can't imagine
something deeper than that but you see a
way for brand to enter that space at the
moment what's different about that is
it's one-to-one communication I mean one
of the biggest debates about snapchat is
can you monetize one-to-one
communication monetizing texting which
is what's whatsapp is is a very
difficult proposition right I mean what
what I think snapchat ultimately will do
is go one too many the way I'm using it
right now by [ __ ] hand I'd like to
have the Select All button they don't
want to do that because it takes away
the intimacy I mean this is me assuming
what they're thinking about
they went half pregnant with stories but
as
[ __ ] experienced in a [ __ ] UI what for
them to truly monetize they're gonna
have to go one too many monetization
works at one too many monetizing one to
one doesn't which is why a lot of people
struggle with whatsapp and things of
that nature so far I'm sure there's some
brilliant girl right now and you know
Scandinavia who's come up with a way to
monetize one to one and I can't wait to
see and I haven't figured it out nobody
else has until somebody shows that or we
get into what I think is gonna happen
which is people gonna start paying for
services right I mean at some level back
to the jokes I was making early on in
the conversation there's going to be a
$20 a month or $20 a year app that might
be one to one that wins its scale cuz
it's so incredibly strong people will
pay people will pay and I think that
that is an interesting variable that I
think has a chance
I always thought path or other people
could go down that route but that's why
people aren't talking about whatsapp or
even snapchat the reason I see snapchat
going that way is much like the way
Twitter felt right to me in oh seven and
I knew what to do with it
snapchats worked that way to me but it's
been one too many it's been able to make
something happen for me at scale what do
you think do you think people in Paris
for example would pay for a bra to
really what's up with them in the future
I think you can make people pay for
anything let me explain
if we went in a time machine and showed
people this and said people in 2013
spent $2 on this [ __ ] they say [ __ ] you
it's free it comes out of this so the
fact that we as human beings pay for
this right here water will pay for
anything I mean it what what it what it
took was somebody figuring out how to
package it and had a story tell right
there's some dumb people in this room to
think these waters are different right
that's good [ __ ] storytelling right
so I think that that's what it's gonna
take but I think that can be done
Helly hey hey you thank you for the
sample on Amazon of your book it's
awesome thank you so much sad to say
that but anyway what is the emotion
created with this attention what is this
access what's the emotional connection
there and is it that we don't have an
emotional connection you know the
emotional connection is completely
predicated by the creative right the
emotional connection is the picture you
actually take that's gonna be different
for everybody and how they story tell
that's actually where the rubber hits
the road right this whole game
distributions mapped word-of-mouth on
the Internet is mapped the social graph
is mapped that red head dude that was
here he mapped it his company well he
the company Facebook they've mapped it
that's not what matters what matters is
what story you actually tell the emotion
is predicated by what you actually put
out there right the emotion you get out
of a song or a movie is based on that
not based on how it was distributed to
you what snapchat is doing is not
changing the emotion what it's doing is
it created a utility that actually gave
you the opportunity to get somebody's
attention in a very noisy world your
book the emotion you create to my mind
is hopefulness the story makes me feel
like something good is can't happen I
can make something happen by what you
show me that's my deal but that's me
being an optimist right you should do it
Church of garyvee thinking about it you
know you good next step you those
churches in the u.s. where you have was
thousands of people and and in business
and wise it's like of what Marc Benioff
is doing we've now let's say for I think
you know you're like 50,000 people
coming and and and because Marc is so
magnetic right yeah no I think I would
say no I think you should do that I went
to go see Book of Mormon on Broadway and
you know these Mormon guys they figured
out a real racket and so you know
starting a religion whatever it gets me
to buy the New York Jets I'll [ __ ]
try it next question what do you think
what do you think the biggest mistake
that young startups and young
entrepreneurs are making in trying to
get new users in this
really really in just busy time with
social media like you're saying you know
I think most the biggest single mistake
that I see young entrepreneurs making is
two things one not realizing that
they're actually not an entrepreneur
right let's address this right and this
is a real real statement this is a real
tough one for me to say because it's a
very it's a very douchebag thing for me
to say but I think it's an important
conversation that we have I think we're
living through a very attractive time to
be an entrepreneur right you know
[ __ ] you know mark put on a hoodie
and a movie came out and you know
Instagram made a billion dollars after
five hundred days and everybody decided
they were an entrepreneur the amount of
Ivy League school kids that I'm meeting
right now who think because they went to
Stanford or Yale or Harvard Brown
what-have-you or anywhere else obviously
I'm in the u.s. that think just because
they're smart students that they're
entrepreneurs that then I watch and the
first taste of adversity that they get
they crumble like a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] and so I think the first mistake
we have right now is we have an issue
where people decided they're
entrepreneurs when they're not you know
I think that's the biggest problem
number two is people think it's a lot
easier than it is I mean listen the
press you for every Instagram there's
five million in stash it right and so
you know like I think we're we're in a
we're not in a bubble financially
because you're not we're not I don't
think celebrities like 120 billion
dollars and Twitter twenty billion
dollars fine but me times profit easy
listen I don't understand anything
snapchat and I'm the [ __ ] doors I'm
the first one carry I made a bit let's
let's explain I made a video the day
Facebook bought Instagram I was on CNN
and I said they stole it you set up here
just a couple hours ago and saying
everybody thought you got killed now it
looks smart right so there's smart buys
you were wrong I was right okay so
so here's what I think here's what I
think week I I think that there's plenty
of things that a thousand seven people
focus where as well and I think in
recent the one that this is not vehicles
we're at the top of a cycle now we're
not
uber and airbnb and nest are just the
beginning of technology eating
everything in our lives this is the big
this is not a cycle this is literally
the beginning we're gonna look back at
this as the early early days there will
be a smart toothbrush and smart pants
and smart [ __ ] and everything we're just
starting so number one I don't think
we're in a bubble i I do think though
we're in a bubble of entrepreneurship I
think there's a lot of pretenders and
there's a lot of idiots like me that are
angel investors who what we do wrong is
we seek some kids come in with a great
idea or a decent idea and we think about
how we would build it as operators and
so we invest not realizing they can't
operate and that's where I've been
caught I mean I think every business
idea is good because I think I can make
every business work and that's a mistake
and that's something I've had a fix was
the mic here over there let's fall over
microphones hi Gary I try to go
everywhere in the room please so we'll
go this way next time so you've heard
about your thought on social media and
you also say you hire two hundred and
eighty people in two years how do you
build a culture how do you make sure
that the people who bring in have the
same view as you have on social media at
vaynermedia very easy I'm the head of HR
comma CEO right
I spend anywhere between two to four
hours a day with talking to employees we
don't have a head of HR still because
the only way to instill the culture for
me is through dictatorship right so I
want them to have a sense of values and
listen we're a very interesting company
I tell everybody I value how you care
about the other boys and girls in this
company more than how skilled you are
and people think I'm joking because it's
a nice thing too
but it then it doesn't get executed it
gets executed in my building we've fired
some of the most talented people because
they weren't willing to be the culture
fits that I want because ultimately I
want to do for vaynermedia what I did
with Wine Library the reason I was able
to leave Wine Library and that sixty
million dollar business is because the
culture was set and it didn't collapse
with me leaving and it's true family I
want to be able to continue to do other
businesses so I'm okay with not letting
it get too big or as big as it can be up
front back to what I talked about
earlier which is I'm constantly in
marathon mode not in sprint mode so I'm
willing to leave 20 to 50 million
dollars on the table with this company
because I'm spending way more time than
I should as a CEO on HR issues because
it's gonna pay me dividends in ten years
it's like the same old story
it's like parenting this is all like
parenting you know when your 15 year old
comes home hi and smashed the car and
all [ __ ] up and you grab your spouse
and say honey
we've got to talk about the kid it's
over you should have talked about the
kid when the kid was five six seven
eight and you didn't give a [ __ ] and you
were going on vacations or work too much
this is about parenting you've got to
put in the work in the first ten years
to get the dividends in the back ten
years
Thank You Paris though it's crazy online
as well it's not only Paris miss I know
you're worldwide the week I put the
kebab I was talking about you think I'm
having fun with you
finally I get you a little upset how are
you fine thank you
where are you from I am from Bolivia
living in Paris my question comes about
sharing sharing yes ok because you're
sharing information but it's important
to know what is the customer
what does you want so having the
customers sharing is very important too
so from my experience I can see that
there are so many cultures where it is
very open so the customer is going to
share on shell so you can analyze the
information yes but you have some other
cultures well the customers will not
share because they feel like they are
being track yet or or whatever so what I
wanted to know is that from your
experience do you think that these
customers will in a day converge to a
same behavior or do you think that we
have to deal with it
this this question is so fun for me
because I don't know if you know this
but I was born in the Soviet Union right
so my heritage is from communism I was
born in Belarus so when I came to the
state's when I was 3 years old by the
time I was 14 I still pretty much grew
up in a Soviet household at least inside
because we were just becoming Americans
so I came from the country that was most
predicated on not sharing I mean my
mother had a refrigerator which was
unheard of in Russia because everybody
was poor and she hid it in her living
room behind a carpet on a wall because
she didn't want her neighbors to know
like the ultimate in hiding information
the truth is absolutely not the habits
of the US consumer or other parts of the
world where they don't fear privacy or
those kind of things they're gonna share
when you go to Venezuela or when you go
to certain parts of the eastern bloc
like Belarus where I come from or other
places they're growing up in a very
different environment and
habits are totally different and it
doesn't become a one-day thing I mean
you're talking about generations of
culture judge when my dad found out six
years ago that his phone number to the
house was on Google it was the worst day
of his [ __ ] life I mean he was
devastated because he grew up in a
culture where privacy was the most
valuable thing and now his son goes to
conferences it says privacy is dead it
doesn't mean anything that's a brain
twister do you think that the
government's are reading your emails
though I think everybody is on the
record 24/7 365 I actually live my life
completely with the thought process that
everything I do is always being looked
at and that's my life I really do now
what does that mean in new revenue your
profit your salary everything everything
I do it in mind
my porn habits oh yeah every actually
money to all that you saw that I mean I
recall that so that they can harm you in
case they need to but I really mean that
I truly live my life I mean I can
someone build a service that will you
know hook into your YouTube channel I
mean account each time you watch porn
need tweets it I'm I think people are
grossly under estimating where the world
goes with this lack of privacy I
actually think it's gonna be very
beneficial I actually can tell you right
now that five years ago I mentally made
that decision as I started getting some
internet fame and people taking pictures
and things of that nature and I've
become a better person because I think
that I'm always on the record it changes
your habits it changes the way you are
and I think we're grossly under
estimating some of the benefits I mean
as the world's gotten more public
kidnapping is down because it's hard to
kidnap because everybody's got a phone
there's a lot of yin and yang everybody
looks at the negative
I think there's enormous positives to a
more transparent world if we know that
we're on the record I mean it changes
quite a bit of behavior cheating you
know there's just a lot of variable
changes I think depending on where you
live you're gonna act differently but I
do yeah but if you build a product like
your startup you build a product you
have to keep it you know I just I don't
think anybody we live in a very cynical
we all see what's going on here and I'm
gonna tell you right now that the far
majority of this crowd right now more
believes that there on the record 24/7
365 than they did two years ago and I
think that's just the beginning of that
friend that really go there thank you
hello I'm Jenny I have two different
Paris
oh well be careful with India I'm not
scared so the end of privacy has you
tell us is also the beginning of the
litter is 'm in history times what do
you think yeah you don't have a very
honestly I haven't thought about that
all the way through but I think that's
right I mean listen we are grossly
grossly grossly under estimating what's
going on right now this room this room
and everybody watching
we're like the people that know what's
going on right and every one of us
including me who prides himself in
understanding consumer mental behavior
of what happens all of us including
myself are grossly grossly under
estimating what's happening I mean when
everybody freaked out when Amazon showed
the drones I watched all the feedback
I'm like what do you guys think I mean
listen we're all gonna become [ __ ]
robots right Google glass that's preview
[ __ ] we're gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna put
[ __ ] all on Me we're gonna be [ __ ]
robots and I mean that I think I think
you know listen if we drop the [ __ ]
caveman in the middle of this room right
now he be like [ __ ] we evolved right we
are I think we're gone I'm een I think
we are dramatically under estimating the
culture shifts and the human shifts that
are really coming and I think the
companies that are the most interesting
to me are actually uber and Airbnb and
nest because they're giving you a
preview of like the real world being a
lot of it in the last 10 years has been
very contained to the digital world
I think our real world is starting to
really be you know dramatically shifted
and intertwined and I think yeah I think
that's one of it I think it's what we
consume I've done
how about Bitcoin Bitcoin is so
confusing to me I'm just not
mathematically smart enough but
yeah I mean bitcoins incredibly like
Napster it's the first version of
something disrupting everything
I mean illegal that he's gonna die and
the next one I thought Facebook Credits
was gonna change the world for all my
predictions that have been right go
watch my keynotes two years ago I said
all of you and use Facebook Credits all
the time to me at some level that was a
preview to Bitcoin I think bitcoins
massively interesting I don't understand
it I really don't just because I don't
understand currency and I'm not
mathematically smart enough to talk on
this issue and haven't done the homework
but yeah I think it's that kind of stuff
I mean I just I'm completely convinced
that all of us in this room will be
flabbergasted what the world looks like
in 15 years
flabbergasted next question here thank
you
my name is Darko I came from Macedonia
we said brands have stories we all have
to have a good stories advisor media do
you help brands develop their story or
do you create stories for them that's a
great question thanks what we do really
well so the answer is both sometimes but
the truth is this is where I think
people get confused you know what we're
really good at what my new books about
and what we do at vaynermedia
we tell stories contextually to the
platform they're in meaning it's I
almost called the book slang marketing
meaning if you want to promote on tumblr
you better know how to make animated
gifs if you want to play on Pinterest
you need to know what an infographic is
you also have to respect the psychology
of the end consumer so a lot of people
in this room no matter what you do
you're using social networks as
distribution to somewhere else
most people here and I was watching all
the web hashtag work most people here
use social networks as modern-day email
services they blast out awareness to
something else they use and they put a
link and they drive you elsewhere I
believe that is the biggest misnomer
around social right now that people are
under estimating storytelling within the
platform right can you teach us yeah so
if you are not put it
gifts do 700% better on tumblr than a
picture for certain brands so you should
do more of that
that is the slang of tumblr right the
proper use of hashtag the amount of
people here that want to create their
own hashtag and start a hashtag or get
their brand or businesses or apps
hashtag trending when they have no
[ __ ] chance versus looking at the 10
hashtags that are actually trending and
looking at them and trying to be
creative to take one of them and still
tell you what they want to say by using
one of the hashtags in there that's a
tactic that we see over 2,000 percent
higher engagement and awareness by using
a hashtag that's already trending and
being creative how to put it into your
copy instead of you thinking how to do
that right psychology a 28 year old
female that's on Pinterest that's on
Facebook at the same exact time has a
very different psychology when she's on
Pinterest
she has intent to buy or aspiration to
buy when she's on Facebook she's getting
informed about her world the way you
have the story tell her in her stream is
very different but everybody here just
puts the same [ __ ] picture on all the
platforms or even worse the worst
[ __ ] move they have their Twitter and
Facebook linked to the maplestory goes
somewhere else stop [ __ ] by doing
that right yeah it makes no sense it
doesn't work and it just proves that we
are trying to use these platforms as
distribution instead of actual places to
tell stories busting Twitter stuff into
Facebook so what we do well is we take
what story they want to do and we make
it contextual to the platform we're
putting out the content on where's the
next microphone yeah people up there I
like those people they're real chill
laid-back just said we want to reward
those who stay with us on stage it's
like they're on stage but sure okay what
you what you don't like those people I
love those people look I love them Gary
thank you so much it's my turn so this
is how you talk after two days of not
sleeping right
imagine if I [ __ ] slap a little time
to wake up okay but first 20 minutes so
quite and now finally we got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] every ten seconds okay
first with two questions first one is
you were just mentioning the let's call
it the state of mind of it's like a lot
for the psychologists platform so when
you're in facebook you have a specific
intention yes maybe this is the reason
why commerce is not working over there
or maybe there is a great way to make
commerce work there but it has to be
aligned with the state of mind so could
you say something about it you know the
answer your the way you say to my
question the question just now makes you
makes me realize that you're thinking
about this properly everybody wants
social to act like search you know when
we search we have intend to by often
which is why it works so well everybody
wanted to apply google adword logic
against facebook ads and it didn't work
so you're absolutely right not to
mention the other reason social is
different than other things in commerce
is social is truly human all the cliche
things that me and Jo over there and
everybody else has been saying for a
long time they're true it is human you
have to be authentic could you imagine
hanging out with somebody who tried to
sell you something out of every time
they ever talk to you you're not gonna
convert so so everybody's in the right
hook right hook right hook right hook
right hook right hook business and when
you know a right hook is coming you duck
so on social the pattern is jab jab jab
right hook give value give value give
value and then ask best can't put by
nest by nest finest they have to give
you infographics of stuff they have they
have to make an interview with the CEO
they have to do testimonials maybe even
something has nothing to do with their
business like happy holidays it's all
jabbing that's setting up the
opportunity to go in for the conversion
so what you say is that cell commerce
can be great
on Facebook but it has to be via a
different way of communicating it this
is what you saying
100 I'm selling not only for mice I mean
the amount of books I'm selling on
Facebook now is incredible to me even
from 2 years ago
because I've learned this pattern it's
why I wrote about it clients that we've
had like remounting coffee or the NFL
where the KPI was how many people did we
convert right how many K Cups for Green
Mountain coffee and they're curing
machine did we sell how many people did
we get the NFL to sign up for their
fantasy product on nfl.com not an ESPN
and all the clients that I get that are
completely conversion based only on
social always hate me for the first six
months and always love me for the back
six months because all we do up front is
jab because we're trying to open up the
window for the opportunity to sell ok
you trick me for the 7 different
questions so can can we meet somewhere
following this session and ask you
question I'm organizing this right now
actually ok where are you you know Gary
you want to meet some thank you very
much should I organize your schedule I'm
available now what's the probability of
well people need to eat yeah I'll just
walk right over there no I'll just walk
we'll just hug it out you will have to
stop vote what no I I II got like upset
at me no we need to go up there now
because Gary was me they paid to write I
know all right I know that so who has a
question yeah as far as we can
who has a question just raise your hand
Seaver quite sure I have no questions
those who have questions are here yeah
one question is it very good hey how's
it going just say what what's the future
of snapchat in your vision you know how
it's gonna go on and we ready crazy to
turn on four billion you know I I I
don't know what snapchat has to prove to
me my favorite conversation since I've
been in this space is when everybody who
didn't know [ __ ] about this said that
Facebook was the next myspace right
remember to act like Facebook's the next
myspace that you should invest in this
because in four or five six years three
or four years there'll be something else
and the reason they were wrong was the
question that we had earlier which was
Facebook was being operated by different
operators than the people that were
operating MySpace
why has Lee Webb been a success for a
decade because two people have operated
this to success there's plenty of
conferences plenty that haven't gotten
as big there's plenty of everything
operations and execution matters right
so Facebook very early on between not
only sucks but the people that I saw
there whether it was Kevin collaring or
Dave Moore and/or Cox or Charlie Cheever
like all those great people you just
knew that they had the quality to
execute and every time they did a
product update news feed things that
were unpopular I believe they were doing
the right thing and I think that's why
there you are where they are today so
far at the height of it mattering
snapchat has made one product update one
that I think is extremely poor so for
the first time ever in two years I'm
actually slightly down on them because
I'm scared if they don't have the
product shops to actually take it to the
next level I can't answer your question
of where it's going because I tend to
not bet on the horse I tend to bet on
the jockey and I don't have a real
understanding yet on this jockey to
really make a bet because I care about
my legacy and I don't want to be wrong
with my prediction right now so I don't
know but over the next year what they do
with the product will really dictate it
this is all execution it matters so much
okay when Lauren will have to stop but
Gary's here so we left you will have to
fall yeah what totally useless hi Gary
my name is Savannah Anderson first of
all congratulations on all your success
thank you speaking about growth I think
the big mistake that many companies make
is growing too fast and just growing for
the sake of growing the the growth at
vaynermedia has accomplished is
impressive you know from 20 to 300
employees in 20 months it's crazy how
have you managed to control the growth
in a way that actually it's growing not
to get bigger but growing to get better
well Vayner is a very different company
right you know remember I I have no
funding
gone from 20 to 300 with zero funding
we've used our own cash flow so we're
building an embolism and I don't think
I'm so cool like plenty of people will
grow to grow and have a huge exit and be
very strategic about it and raise money
and do well for me it's been very easy
we're growing slower than I'd like
because I truly believe our agency with
who we compete with can do better work
than anybody in the marketplace but I
can only grow so fast because I do have
a P&L I do have b2b clients that pay me
a hundred twenty day terms so I can only
grow so quickly right you know I'm very
very very very proud of how quickly
we've grown completely predicated by our
own cash flow and our own execution I
think it's a good story for people to
pay attention to if they actually care
about actually building a business
versus just building headcount you know
I want more headcount I just can't
afford it yet sad I mean you know Kerry
you're happy you came because I know
you've not slept and take a look for you
the week that I came I'm kidding I love
the week I of course I'm happy this is
the the one of the premier events in the
world
enough with this premier event in Europe
this is one of the premier events in the
world you know I'm very proud to have
been coming here for a long time I've
missed it for the last year or two that
I haven't been here I see a lot of
familiar faces I hope I see some new
faces as I walk out here and I'm just
very thankful for your attention that
allowing me to talk so should we
organize you to like so we go somewhere
and you keep meeting people that you
want a promised I actually have a like
some interviews that I'm supposed to do
so I don't want to be powerful probably
Oh buy me a time that works for you for
them yeah I mean what time is it it's
one right now okay so I have to go do an
interview that I promised in the press
room but I'm more than happy to meet in
the main hall at 140 how about okay 140
yeah okay varies a better building for
that if I may how about doing it in the
husband building and the team will show
you because there is most more sitting
space it feels complicated it's
easy hustlin building 145s where it's
easy thank you thank you very much